in this video
i'm going to give you a very quick
introduction to how our transformer
models work together
with tensorflow and keras the very short
explanation is that all of our
tensorflow models are also keras model
objects
and so they have the standard keras
model api
if you're an experienced machine
learning engineer who's used keras a lot
that's probably all you need to know to
start working with them but for everyone
else
including the the prodigal pie torch
engineers out there who are returning to
the fold
i'm going to quickly introduce keras
models and how we work with them
in other videos which i'll link below
i'll run through training with keras
models in more detail
but first at a high level what is a
keras model
so your model basically contains your
entire network
it contains the layers and the weights
for those layers
and also tells the model what to do with
them so it defines the whole path
all the way from your inputs to your
outputs
if you've used keras before you probably
started using model objects by
building them out by hand you added one
layer after another
maybe using the model.add or the
functional approach
and there's nothing wrong with that you
can lots of great models are built that
way
but you can also preload an entire model
weights and all
and this is really helpful because if
you as you can see here
if you try reading the paper or if you
try looking at the code you'll see the
inside of a transformer
is pretty complex and writing it all out
from scratch and getting it right would
be hard even for an experienced machine
learning engineer
but because it's all packed inside a
model you don't
need to worry about that complexity on
that if you don't want to if you're a
researcher if you want to
really dig in there you can but you can
also just
load a pre-trained pre-configured
transformer model in just one line of
code
and when i mentioned earlier about the
keras api
the advantage of it is that whether you
write your own model from scratch
or load a pre-trained one you interact
with the model through that same api so
you use
exactly the same few methods and you're
going to see them again and again these
methods like
fit compile and predict and like i
mentioned
we'll see cover concrete examples of how
to use those methods in the videos i'll
link below
for now the key thing to take away from
this video if you've never seen keras
before
is that this neat encapsulation means
that all the complexity of a huge neural
net becomes manageable
because you interact with it in exactly
the same way using exactly the same
methods
whether it's a huge pre-trained language
model or a simple model you wrote out by
hand